5 55 on your friday morning how about
seeing neighborhood traffic in a whole
new
light around the 95 in the northern 215
beltway come on let's go
centennial bowling a lot of times when
we're talking about the centennial we're
talking about the big picture which
kind of makes sense when you're talking
about hundreds of millions of public
dollars being spent on making
transportation easier on all of us but
with the explosive residential growth in
the area there's something else that's
important too
traffic signals like these they were
just
activated a week ago today that's the
sign for sky
village drive and this is grand teton
now on the south side of grand teton sky
village is still known as
hualapai and there is a set of traffic
signals almost ready to go just east of
hualapai as you go down grand teton at
grand canyon
and the city of las vegas where they've
already put in lights at a couple of
other intersections they got plans for
several more
which you can read about in the online
version of this story at
eightnewsnow.com you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com